you also host a show called skin Wars
body painting competition show body and
body painting show and you've had quite
a lot of experience having your body
paint I have I was I played for see yes
first three x-men movies that was a lot
of body painting and I was also the very
first model painted for the Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue yes I happen
to have something I remember that I
remember that very well I don't need to
sound creepy I don't mean to sound
creepy in any way but I remember that
day when you and I remember that day
very well I remember that much better
than when sintra Klaus shows up it is
magic Carrie visiting you that's
purchase no no no but you you did the
Sports Illustrated first model to do to
get your body paint yeah that is I gotta
say that's got to be an amazing job for
the person painting your body dude is it
women doing it or doing it women mostly
women you know it's funny it's a once
you're painted go with me on this okay
you don't feel nude you actually do feel
very covered up and you can tell from
people's body language that they don't
feel naked well I mean I obviously so
it's an even though it's an illusion you
are in fact naked the fact that they've
painted clothes on you makes you feel
less self-conscious yes Wow
yeah that is so weird I'm wondering if I
did a show an episode of this show where
I had a suit and a tie painted on me but
I was completely naked
[Applause]
I would do it if you came on as the
guest painted painted yes really yeah
okay
[Music]
two questions how much time do I have to
work out between now and that scope and
can I have certain surgeries you're
already starting to take it off when you
do skin wars on that show people are I
mean are people walking around naked on
the set yeah much because the canvas is
the naked body and we have female models
we have male models they're bits because
of standards and practices who police is
everything we do on television their
bits are covered up with pasties and
thongs and everybody's wearing under we
might if we do our nude show I'm sure
I'm going to have to find some way to
restrain all that right I can't have
that thing I can't walk out dragging
that firehose out here we got
[Music]
it's not practical you know everyone
could get hurt her I out
yeah there you go dangerous so anywho
but you know I kids come to set they you
kids come to the same kid we're making
it's love painting and they and the cat
other points know the caliber of art is
fantastic I'm sure it is they love the
challenges are amazing they have a
superhero challenge and people it's you
know they've got all these models
walking around but one of my daughters
did point to a male model and say I fear
where I see here weiner slightly
mortified yeah was the guy was the guy
okay with it it was very good
you